hey chris hey
love the show love you guys you already
know all right
taking breaks on social media so i know
it's absolutely necessary everyone
should take breaks when they need to uh
i would just like to know maybe your
perspective on how you navigate
breaks from social media
uh especially if there's an influence of
income from your social media presence
uh so with that is there such thing as
too long of a break or should you just
not even care and always
take as much of a break as you need no
matter what income is influenced uh good
or bad so would love to know your guys's
thoughts on that i'm kind of going
through that dilemma myself and you know
just hearing your guys personal
experience i think will will help a lot
in that uh in that situation so
appreciate you guys bye-bye
he's [ __ ] hilarious i know he's so
hilarious on tick-tock or instagram or
whatever it is yeah every time he
comments on my thing his name is like
jason rodello or something and every
time he comments on my thing i'm like oh
[ __ ] jason derulo commented on my [ __ ]
no but and then
dance is better than jason way better
guys [ __ ] hilarious way better he
reminds me of first time i saw him i was
like that's like alfred molina and
boogie yeah yeah yeah 100 he's he's like
out for melina when he was a kid so um
well anyway he
he is very funny uh yeah okay i have a
[ __ ] thing about this actually
um
you got to make those racks right if
that's how you're making racks and
that's how you make an income then great
but money is never as important as your
[ __ ] mental health right so
man [ __ ] uh
social media [ __ ] up your mental health
like i can't even go on a lot of the
social media i go on you know i post an
instagram i'll post a tick tock and i
don't really look at i definitely the
only thing i really kind of look at is
instagram but um
but
this is what you do
if you take a break
you happen to be taking a break you
don't say
hey guys
i'm taking a break
that's the most annoying [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass oh yeah
social media as egotistical [ __ ] guys
just to let you know i'll be taking a
break from [ __ ] social media and
you're just like you don't call your
friends to tell them they're to tell
them you're staying home if they didn't
invite you out like who gives a [ __ ]
hello hey rick what's up yeah hey dude
just to let you know i'm staying home
tonight cool didn't ask
if you'd like to make a call please hang
up and try again
message c5
yeah actually that's true i never
thought about that but that's so [ __ ]
true dude it's so annoying these chicks
with like 2 500 followers are like guys
it's just getting to my brain mental
health is real i'll be taking a break
for a month and then [ __ ] six days
later they're like
whoopsie went to kirks and caicos here's
the undercarriage of my anus oh my god
oh my god i saw [ __ ] that shot where
they shoot it like this or they're like
this i'm unfamiliar and they're like
glutes be popping
wow they're like wow caked up and you're
just like all right
with this [ __ ]
boner
i saw i followed this guy who this is
the worst one i've ever seen he typed it
out on his computer and took a picture
of it oh wow and posted it yeah was it
[ __ ]
like a 70 year old
that's insane he's younger than me oh my
god i love to think of the whole like
imagine him and then yeah
i think he wrote it out in final giraffe
too no he's a right yeah
so bad one
wants to flex that he's got deals i'm
sorry to say it yeah wow dude don't
think he has deals um but
i think that i agree with what
my brother just said but i also just
from personal experience
i've gone through phases where i've been
like without even realizing it just
checking instagram incessantly that's
right that's good and i and then i've
gone through phases where i'm
at first i'll force myself to stop
checking incessantly and then i just
will stop yeah and now i'm in a place
where like i don't really i think it's
more about how often you check it right
it's not about how much you post it's
about how much you check right yeah yeah
well yeah that's i mean posting is fine
is is what it is that takes no time sure
but also the checking
of it almost up in my mouth the checking
of it is what makes you
is the is the what makes you feel bad
about yourself yeah so stop checking
right i know that's what i'm saying yeah
but um stop checking jason and also the
the first day you do it is easier the
second day you do it like dude when i
get a [ __ ] burger from in and out the
next thing i want to do is get a burger
from in and out but if i don't eat a
burger from in and out then i don't want
a burger for right now right yeah yeah
yeah that's true too you're being smart
today
well
it's not always what the feelings are
no we love that guy though jason uh
yellow and he's funny as [ __ ] you should
follow him on tick tock i know he's
taking a break maybe but i'm not on
tick-tock i fall on my instagram it's
[ __ ] great you know you're a boy's on
tick-tock because he goes stupid viral
right what's that my [ __ ] goes mean and
all right
my your boy is you yeah me got it and it
goes my my numbers go nuts okay it's
crazy it's like that some people look at
it they're like what is it this is dow
jones like i don't even understand
getting ahead
[Music]
hello
hello
hello
[Music]